[Music]
ultimate power let's turn up the heat to
save our world hope i'm not too late
he'll need some help i mean say goodbye
i think we lost
we did not lose him this
knuckles you are really bad at punching
like vin diesel and the rock
so nice when diabolical evil lives up to
the height oh i think we lost him
nope he's not lost he's very not lost
these rings signify the commitment
so help me thomas sorry sorry
life or death situation i need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
snowmaker oh boy
ah hawaii i just hope we are not too
late oh lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
robotnik is back
i discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back for the world is
doomed
you got some kind of
space porcupine
i am an echidna warrior
hmm
hedgehog
it's time to say goodbye to humanity
welcome
to the new norm
this is your moment to be the big hero
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh
someone call an uber
it's cold in here
let's turn up the heat
oh great the winter soldier
fear not citizens you are terrible at
this your negative attitude is not
helping
we stick together
no matter what
you're unskilled
untrained
unworthy
you forgot one
unstoppable
[Music]
for a guy named knuckles you are really
bad at punching
[Music]
you